now that we're back from e3 we know
about a ton of new games coming out in
the future but for PlayStation Plus
subscribers there's a batch of new free
games on the way in July if you want to
know what's being offered I've got you
covered
first up on ps4 is heavy rain tying in
with Detroit become humans release in
May this other Quantic Dream game has
you tracking down the origami killer
from four different perspectives
branching storylines and QuickTime
events are here in spades also coming to
ps4 is absolve er no QuickTime events
here this game is all about the action
in fact you can build your own custom
fighting style by stringing together all
sorts of attacks and combos before we
move on to other consoles there's one
more freebie for you to grab on ps4 in
anticipation of black ops for launching
this fall you can download black ops 3
right now but only until July 11 moving
to ps3 you can also enjoy the
platforming fun of rayman 3 HD in this
entry our limbless hero can collect
power-ups for temporary special
abilities as he battles andre in his
army of black lumps and yes this HD
version does look and run better than
the original if you're more the
strategic type you can plot your way to
victory in deception for the nightmare
princess this expanded version of
deception for Blood Ties still puts you
in the shoes of the devil's daughter who
can lay all sorts of crazy traps and
lure her victims right into them Vita
fans can also flex those brain muscles
with zero escape zero time dilemma like
other games in the series your goal here
is to solve escape room style puzzles
but here's the twist you choose which
rooms to enter each based on a different
characters memory and yes that does mean
it has multiple endings finally Vita
owners can also try out space overlords
you play as the overlords themselves
whose goal is to destroy various planets
you can do that with friends and local 4
player co-op or online with 8 total
players and thanks to cross play you can
also do it all on ps4 and ps3 and those
are your free PS Plus games for July
they'll be available from Tuesday July
3rd until August
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on GameSpot and if you want to
watch us discuss news like this you can
tune in to GameSpot daily that show airs
weekdays at 11:00 a.m. Pacific
[Music]